hey thoughty2 here on the 6th of
December 1966 four guys from Liverpool
stepped into Abbey Road Studios and
began to record an album 333 hours and
many questionable substances later the
beetle had emerged having produced their
eighth album sergeant pepper's Lonely
Hearts Club but it would go on to sell
over 32 million copies worldwide and be
named the greatest album of all time by
Rolling Stone magazine and many other
publications it was highly experimental
using mold breaking techniques and a
huge array of unusual instruments the
band had produced an emotional
masterpiece that epitomized the so
called
Summer of Love and was a true
masterpiece of its time yet it remains
just as relevant and powerful today fast
forward 44 years to 2010 I'm Justin
Bieber released his hit single baby this
is generally considered to be a bad move
so what went wrong how did we go from
Bob Dylan to Britney Spears from Led
Zeppelin to Lady Gaga and the kinks to
Katy Perry but who am I to criticize the
musical pace of the vast majority of
today's youth personally my musical
taste is stuck in the middle of last
century but you may think that just
makes me old-fashioned stuck in the past
and I should probably move of the times
but here's the thing there is far more
to this and simple nostalgia and when
your parents keep telling you that the
music died long ago they may actually
have a point because it turns out that
science agrees with them over the past
30 plus years researchers have been
studying how trends in music have
evolved and the recent study in 2012 by
the spanish national research council
revealed that the suspicions of somewhat
antiquated individuals such as myself
are very true music is getting worse
every year the researchers took around
500,000 recordings from all gel
music from the period of 1955 to 2010
and they meticulously run every single
song through a set of complex algorithms
these algorithms measured three distinct
metrics of each song the harmonic
complexity the timbrel diversity and
loudness the most shocking results that
the researchers found was that over the
past few decades Tamra in songs has
dropped drastically Sombra is the
texture color and the quality of the
sounds within the music in other words
the songs richness and depth of sound
the researchers found that timbrel
variety peaked in the 1960s and has
since been steadily declining the
timbrel palette has been homogenized
meaning songs increasingly have less
diversity with their instruments and
recording techniques this divide is
clearly evident if we take what is
widely considered to be the Beatles
masterpiece a day in the life which was
recorded using an orchestra of 14
musicians but this is not classical
music this is pop the five-minute piece
contains violins violas cellos double
bass harp clarinet and oboe bassoons
flutes French horns trumpets trombones a
tuba and of course the four band members
playing their usual instruments over the
top
in contrast Robin Thicke's blurred lines
uses mostly one instrument a drum
machine and yes it is a rather extreme
example a song known for its
one-dimensional but punchy bass line but
it represents an overall trend with
modern pop music that the researchers
found within their data instead of
experimenting with different musical
techniques and instruments the vast
majority of pop today is built using the
exact same combination of keyboard the
drum machine sampler and computer
software this might be considered as
progressive by some people putting truth
it sucks the creativity and originality
out of music making everything sound
somewhat similar
do you ever flick through the radio and
think to yourself all these songs sound
the same well what the researchers found
is that the melodies rhythms and even
the vocals of popular music have become
more and more similar to each other
since the 60s one facet of this
modernization of popular music was
pointed out by musical blogger patrick
mexico metzger noted that hundreds of
pop artists were using the exact same
sequence of notes in which there's a
shift from the fifth note in a scale to
the third note and then back to the
fifth this sequence of notes is usually
accompanied by a vocal wah Oh wah
passant Metzker named this the
millennial group and it sounds like this
wah wah wah wah the millennial whoop can
be found in hundreds of chart-topping
pop songs create over the past few years
and it's usage is becoming more frequent
all the time from Katy Perry's
California Gurls to Justin Bieber's baby
literally every single major pop star
today has included the millennial group
in at least one of their songs but why
well quite simply familiarity our brain
likes familiarity the more we hear the
same sound the more we enjoy them the
millennial group has become a powerful
unpredictable way to subconsciously say
to the masses hey listen to this new
song it's really cool but don't worry
you will like it because it's also
really familiar because you've actually
heard it hundreds of times before and in
this wildly unpredictable world this
makes us feel safe sticking to the same
cookie cutter formula comforts people
and that's important but what about
lyrics well I'm afraid it's bad news
there too another study examined the so
called lyric intelligence of hundreds of
Billboard chart topping songs over the
past 10 years they use different metrics
such as the fleshier Kincaid readability
index which indicates how difficult a
piece of
taxes to understand and the quality of
the writing this was the result over the
past 10 years the average lyric
intelligence has dropped by a full grade
lyrics are also getting sure to intend
to repeat the same words more often
we've gone from the absolute poetic
beauty of Bob Dylan and Morrissey to
well this and this what if I also told
you that the vast majority of
chart-topping music in the past 20 years
was written by just two people
what do Britney Spears Taylor Swift
Ellie Goulding Robin Thicke Jessie J
Justin Bieber Katy Perry ariana grande
Justin Timberlake maroon 5 pink Leona
Lewis Avril Lavigne Christina Aguilera
Ke$ha the Backstreet Boys Westlife and
Singh Adam Lambert and will I am all
have in common the answer their
songwriter I'm not saying 100% of their
songs but a good chunk of all these
artists songs were written by the same
Swedish man a mr. max Martin this one
man is single-handedly responsible for
over two dozen number-one singles and
thousands of songs in the top 100 charts
over the past decade he has written
universally recognizable tracks such as
I kissed a girl baby one more time since
you being gone California girls shake it
off and so so many more and if Max
Martin didn't write it then American
singer-songwriter Lucas got world's most
probably bit known professionally as dr.
Luke together with Max Martin they
account for the lyrics and melodies
behind the vast majority of pop music
today you've likely never heard of them
and that is very intentional these two
men are the hidden pop factories behind
virtually every single band that has
played on the radio today and probably
every musical act you grew up with
if you
under 30 years old and you wondered why
everything sounds the same there are
still popular chart-topping musicians
that write the entirety of their own
music today but you have to look really
really hard research has also shown that
the hook the part of the song that
really grabs us and pulls in is
occurring sooner in modern songs and
they happen more often researchers
believe this is because when it comes to
music our attention spans have
drastically shortened unless the song
innocently grabs us our brain tends to
shut off and ignore it often skipping to
the next song this shortened attention
span is a trend amongst people that has
only occurred in the past 10 years and
it's believed to have been caused by the
instant access to millions of songs at
our fingertips it used to be the case
that if you want to do hear a song you
have to go out and buy that one single
or album take it home and play it you'll
probably play it countless times because
you had spent so much money on so few
songs over time you would learn to
appreciate all the subtle nuances
throughout the album and then the iPod
happened granting access to thousands of
songs on one device which eventually led
to streaming today we flick through
songs on Spotify without much force to
each song subtleties and unique talents
this had caused musicians and record
companies to favor punchy bass lines
that demand our attention and to stuff
each song full of so-called hooks to
instantly grab our attention and keep it
for as long as possible and they've also
been doing something else in recent
years to grab our attention something
subtle but so very powerful yet so very
very wrong for the past 20 years music
producers have been engaged in a war the
loudness war the aim of this war is to
produce louder music than your
competitors but how do you make music
louder when the listener is in control
not that producer well they use
compression you may have heard of
dynamic range compression it's the
process of boosting the volume of the
quietest parts of a song so that they
must a loudest parts thus reducing the
dynamic range the distance between the
loudest part and the quietest part this
makes the whole song sound much much
louder than the uncompressed version no
matter what volume the listener has set
their device to it's like me standing in
the middle of the street and mumbling
nonsense to myself occasionally whispers
and sometimes speaking a bit louder a
few people might notice under worried me
what's there and if I were to compress
my dynamic range I would suddenly be
bellowing out every single word at the
top of my voice loudly and proudly
suddenly everyone turns around to look
at the crazy man shouting in the street
under police would be called but this is
exactly why producers do it as the
market has become increasingly crammed
with similar sounding pop music making
your song shout louder than all the
others ensures it will be heard amongst
all the competition but there's a big
price to pay for loudness the dynamic
range compression when abused as it
often is today is an absolute travesty
when it comes to the art of creating
music where physics is concerned the
rule is that you can't make a sound
louder than the volume it was recorded
at without reducing its quality
compressing a song dynamic range strips
away timbrel variety it muddies the
sound subtle nuances that would have
before been very noticeable and could
have been appreciated are now no longer
nuanced they sound exactly the same as
the rest of the track listen to this
short recording without any compression
[Music]
now here what happens when the dynamic
range is compressed to match that of
modern pop music here how everything
sounds less punchy and vibrant the drum
beats stand out less everything just
makes less of an impact but at the end
of the day there is very real reason why
popular musicians and producers today
don't stray away from their safe haven
of repetitive monotonous drum machine
unimaginative factory produced lyrics
rhythms stolen from the previous popular
song and shut up and changed slightly
and of course their ever-popular
millennial whoops it all has to do with
risk in the fifties sixties and
seventies record labels would receive
hundreds of demo tapes from putting
young artists every week they would sift
through them and the most talented acts
would be offered record contracts even
they weren't that special it didn't
matter too much the record label would
just throw a few thousand pounds into
marketing and if the public liked their
music they would naturally gain traction
and make it big if not they would fade
away into the night and this is crucial
because importantly the public were
voting was there is for the best the
most talented musicians singers and
songwriters we the people were the final
judge and jury the ultimate arbiter and
so musicians had to be really bloody
talented too impressive enough to stick
around and make more music there was
just no room for sloppiness or the
untalented but this method was risky
because many times
labels would pump thousands of pounds
into an act that weren't destined to be
and their gamble wouldn't pay off losing
their investment but when they signs the
really big acts it would balance the
books however today promoting a new band
is more expensive than ever over time
the cost of breaking in a new artist
onto the global music scene has
skyrocketed in fact the IFPI reports
that today it costs anywhere between
half a million and three million dollars
to sign a new act and break them into
the music scene that's a hell of a lot
of money would you want to gamble with
three million dollars no neither do
music producers so the industry has
reacted by removing the risk instead of
trying to find genuine musical colors
they simply take a pretty young faith
usually from a TV talent show and then
simply force the public to like them by
brainwashing them instead of allowing
the public to grow to like an artist and
make their own mind off about the
quality of their music the industry now
simply makes you like their music thus
removing all the financial risk
brainwash you say how on earth do they
do that well have you ever noticed how
that's popular new song seems to follow
you around everywhere you go it's on
every single radio station it's played
in your favorite stores to supermarket
all over the internet and even in the
latest Hollywood movies and popular TV
shows this is no coincidence what that
is in fact is the record labels three
million dollars making sure that that
new single is quite literally everywhere
completely unescapable
you will hear it whether you want to or
not
remember I was talking about the power
of familiarity it's called the
mere-exposure effect a psychological
phenomenon by which people develop a
preference for things they see and hear
often our brain releases dopamine when
we hear a song that we've heard a few
times before and the effect only gets
stronger with
listen can you remember the very first
time you heard your favorite pop songs
in the past ten years whether it be
Gangnam style happy all about that base
load line hotline bling' did you truly
like it the first time you heard it or
were you in fact kind of repulsed pick
you up this brief moment when you
thought what the hell is this what then
you heard it a few more times and you
began to think well I guess it's kind of
catchy and then your friends are all
listening to it and new here is a few
more times and boom it's your new
favorite song and you can't stop playing
if this has happened to you then I'm
afraid you have been brainwashed the
mere-exposure effect has worked on you
surely if a song is a truly great song
then you wouldn't need to force yourself
to love it you wouldn't need to be won
over for a period of repeated exposure
you would just like it the first time
you've heard it we all have different
musical tastes but they are subtly being
overridden diluted and emulsified by the
brainwashing activities of big record
labels the repeated and constant
exposure to manufactured songs that
we've heard a hundred times before don't
get me wrong there are many
fantastically talented bands out there
today but in today's industry virtually
none of them will ever be signed because
they are simply too risky to promote
because they don't fit the usual pop
formula they are different but being
different is important you may be
thinking so what have I been brainwashed
I enjoy contemporary popular music and
isn't that what's most important at the
end of the day yes of course music is an
expression of your personality and it
should be enjoyed no matter what others
think or say but it's also really
important to not let creativity and
originality disappear music as an art
form is dying it's being replaced by
music which is a disposable product
designed to sell or not to inspire so we
shouldn't be so complain
in allowing systemic cold
factory-produced music to dominate or
else the beautiful soulful and truly
real music that we all at some point
loved and had been there with us through
our darkest times and our happiest times
could soon be a distant memory never to
be repeated thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video then please click
here to support me on patreon which
really helped out the channel and you
can get some cool rewards like early
access to all my videos click here to
watch another video and if you haven't
already don't forget to subscribe